i love it he gets all excited and then
not sure what to go for
yep
i'm a little high energy
oh
the clock is sticking on what are you
doing
[Music]
this isn't the world championship but it
is the pog championship and we have the
matchup that i think many have been
waiting for in box box and ludwig and we
expect the scandinavian and we also
probably expect a lot of you know a lot
of big dancing and
doing ridiculous things
and ludwig looks deep in thought
we can't really tell what he looks like
we just use his forehead
just develop smiley face
can you play d5 no
wait
no
i take tonight he takes with pawn i take
pawn of check
destroyed on every street
you lose
damn he's in the tank
did developing my knight really stump
him that hard
bro it's a night relax
you're being cringed
but if it seems a little bit more salty
than usual
did it stall
i mean i guess i don't know why i'm
complaining i guess it's good for me
let's get my bishop out i think he's
gonna pawn push but i don't think i'm
too concerned
because i just played d7 and then if he
pushes again i can just capture on it
with e6 takes d6 or e47 takes d6 and
then i have a a block from that bishop
line because c7 protects d6 pawn
oh uh-huh yeah so we did talk about is
this the proud coach moment
d7
proud is one way of putting it and uh
and then if he pushes again
you know whatever
i'll just play this is your prodigy
roberto
wow okay well plenty of teaching moments
both in life and in chess and the first
one comes at this point here so the move
a6 is played to take away the b5 square
from white's pieces and this becomes
immensely important right here after the
trade bishop to b5 would pin the queen
the queen and the king are on the same
diagonal so bishop b5 would win the
queen if not for this pawn so it's one
of the reasons why you make this side
pawn move early on to take away some of
white's options but as the game
developed andrea i think both players
are playing quite well and you're used
to this move bishop g6 being a london
player the retreat
yep they don't want to trade they'd
rather just retreat and if you take you
take back with the h-pawn and everything
is pretty solid you have nothing to
worry about peace and then wait can i
just do this
he's gotta find it
i'm sorry i saw that and just played it
i didn't even what did you base that
just seemed like you're great playing
with your emotions
he's very good at tactics
i mean maybe he's like a sick attack
he's still working on
i so desperately want to play like queen
g42
after this queen leaves because like
queen g4 hits the bishop and hits the
pawn on g2 but i feel like i should be
more concerned about my king's safety
for now and so i can't i can't like i
want to do dope my king is such a s
he's such a softy he's used two twitch
bandwords i've actually never seen him
be this bitter in a game of chess i
don't know you you know him better than
i do what you have to understand is the
first time he was just singing a song
the second time he's somewhat
simplifying the position because if
you're going to win material in this
event a rook is worth more than a bishop
and the queen has to move you take the
rook then you want to simplify the
position and make your life easier so
that's just translating ludwig into
thank you you know a queen traders offer
so the
simplification
that ludwig was looking for is he can
trade queens and then take this rook the
queens are off his king can breathe a
sigh of relief because your king is okay
being the center it won't be as attacked
as easily with queens off the board
thank you for enlightening us with your
your wisdom robert let's see what boxbox
is thinking normally i wouldn't want to
trade queens once i'm already done in
exchange
but i see one reason why i might be okay
with it here
so since i already got wrecked i need to
get creative
let's throw him into a situation where
he might blunder
[Music]
let's do some peripheral axis
he wants to trade it off i won't let you
he's going prophylaxis peripherals
yeah i was like i don't know that one
yet
or something new every day actually
he calls it frappuccino because it's
easier for him to remember
it's the end of the game he can't even
check me
i guess i'm just not used to this angle
of ludwig you just seem so much more
angry than usual
look at that move he wants to push that
pawn he's attacking the light square
bishop but if he gets it one square
forward he can trap the door's actually
pretty good for me
this is crushing yeah f4 is like g5 his
bishop could be trapped oh true
his instinct seems good by moving the
rook but he's spending a lot of time
it's about to be a bullet game and in
their winner stays match ludwig won the
longer time control portion but then box
bus crushed him
in bullet
oh yeah i know they've been this is a
long-awaited match-up and audrey was
very i'm gonna go here
i think he's gonna go back but i just
wanna build up a little time on the
clock
oh yeah i'm curious if he has a mouse or
not
yes it's contemporary it seems like it's
not a touch pad no
i hope it doesn't go into tie breaks
that would be really unfortunate
i'm sure mr beast has an extra
mouse he said he's like for thousands of
dollars you set up the f4 which traps
the bishop oh and boxbox plays in the
queen side
oh my goodness
he got it
he is trapping that [__] himself
i don't know why
oh great move by box box though
wow i i completely overlooked this move
oh gosh unless it took the bishop
allowing this check
thank god he fell for my countertrap
those 2100 tactics
paying off
if he made one careful move he would
have won that game right
there oh my goodness walking into
another potential pin
yeah
oh he sucked
thank you mr daniel
you don't want to put your king on the
scene colored the bishop and i win this
box sees it oh my gosh and loving walks
into it
oh my gosh
right into it the check here gave it all
away like mr beast he gave all of his
rooks away first this rook over here had
he played
the move rook g7 he would have protected
and saved his rook instead he went
opposed to tags and now he lost
second yeah
damn i'm choking
feels bad man clap
oh box box playing this well though
bring his rook to attack the pawn there
i know let me get such a good game until
he just played those two moves so quick
and take that pawn
the clicking is really loud oh his
bishop's under attack so he takes that
pawn don't take the pawn don't take the
pawn take it oh
it's gone
uh all right well we lost this one
vladimir needs to learn from cutie
though and have a mental reset after
this game
do you think you should use this isn't
doing it on purpose all right
i shouldn't give it to him
should i give him the checkmate
opportunity
okay do you see it albert
he did uh you do but not there were no
pawns one could have been stalemate
which works true
and that's mate
oh no he did see it wait i could have
gone up true
okay
ah dude i threw that game i had him by
the balls for a minute
well box box returns and makes his move
quickly and typically ludwig plays the
scotch pawn d4 and let's see what ludwig
is going to do
in this game as he is yet to make his
third turn
because it's time boys
for the italian game
let's go
all right we got a mental reset you're
feeling good this is what we want to see
they exited the eu i'm out of that
i'm european until the day i die
of course he's dancing i love it he gets
all excited and then
not sure what to go for
yep
i'm a little high energy
oh
the clock is sticking on what are you
doing
what'd they say you're gonna go for a
little jog clearing your head
[Music]
all right i'm ready
should i try the fried liver attack it'd
be kind of fun if we get a fried liver
let's do a fried liver i don't think it
works
i think a better move than fried liver
would probably be like queen h5
and then he brings his pawn forward one
and then what
no i think it's fried liver it up bro
oh boy cried liver time this got to be
the world's first fried liver in pog
camps right
it's like when you know the sack doesn't
work but you just you want something
different you just go for it anyway i've
been there before i wouldn't you know
advice
but advice
yeah i don't know if this is a fried
liver or cirrhosis of the liver but it's
not good like this is not a good
sacrifice it might scare box box but
objectively he's
okay now queen check on f3
i'm threatening the knight
on
d5
so he needs to protect the knife by
playing e6 with his king
i think he's forgetting that the knight
can move backwards because in the fried
lip oh my gosh there's a really
important distinction
and i understand why he's jumbling the
lines
why robert give us the explanation
okay here we go fried liver time in the
fried liver at the start knight g5 the
point is attacking the f7 square the
only way to defend is by blocking and
after pawn takes knight takes d5
now you take on f7 because when the king
takes and you give this check here
there's a check to the king but also to
the knight and the knight is pinned to
the king because of the bishop so he's
not looking at the knight retreating or
moving because in the fried liver the
knight cannot legally move so that's
what happens when you sort of mix up the
ideas in positions that may seem similar
but aren't queen go here and now there's
this thread of bishop g5 check the
knight comes in oh look at the
evaluation bar andrea he didn't he
needed like an h6 or something stop that
check
now let's see if ludwig is gonna go for
the attack
he simply must because he is down
material
the king with my bishop
i imagine i should
i don't really know how it follows
obviously
seems good
let's do it
there we go
actually seems really good for me he had
the bishop like on the e5 pawn and on
the other queen but the truth yeah
he threw me off first i feel like this
is really good for me
have i said that
because if he goes e8 then i can check
with the queen
then he's forced to go
f8
i don't know how it finishes
and he's still thinking
okay let's go rookie one
ah this could be a mistake but if
anyone's mad at me for not knowing the
theater the theoretical ending of this
game at move 17 then you know
i guess uh he's talking to me i made it
an exciting evil bar just say that
oh my god
[Music]
not like this and that was lovely's
expression before
oh my goodness
let's check oh
yeah he found it and cause cindy about
to play blitz andrea being on a trackpad
is really really bad yeah it's really
stressful i honestly feel bad but i mean
luckily this game he has increments so
there's hope for the tiebreak
and he doesn't even have auto queen on
so the keyers always give checks and i
think ludwig knows that
here's yup brings his queen there we go
oh he didn't no
never mind not me
what
what what was that
he's trying no don't don't pre-move that
that is over
sometimes
oh my god he could actually steal me no
this is really really bad
do not do that because what is happening
you can accidentally stalemate if you do
this the king might go the other way
buddy
oh
oh my god uh-oh
oh no never mind no boxing no it's gonna
be a stalemate it's gonna be a stalemate
he's still there
oh my don't do it he's gonna do it don't
do it don't do it
yeah
i move
like a staircase
yes
oh
my god
now i see my box
dude that is
funny will be anything on your mind
right now
pass i'm feeling money dude i played out
of my mind i owned that nerd for opening
game one then i choked the bag that was
all you baby game two [__] him
pre-moved the most ludwig thing that
could have possibly happened
uh it'll be great for my clip channel
not so great for my chess repertoire
[Music]
you